mr. Leonard mountain is film critic and
the host of Multan on movies his annual
reference book Leonard mountains movie
guide was first published in 1969 he has
served as the president of Loess at the
Los Angeles Film Critics Association and
is a guest curator at the Museum of
Modern Art mr. Moulton is a member of
the board of directors of the National
Film Preservation Foundation he has
written for numerous publications
including the New York Times the Los
Angeles Times the London Times premier
Smithsonian TV Guide Esquire and the
Village Voice he's the author of
numerous books as well including Leonard
mountains movie encyclopedia the great
American broadcast great movie comedians
of mice and magic a history of American
animated cartoons the art of the
cinematographer and most recently
Leonard mountains 151 best movies you've
never seen please welcome me in joining
our speaker tonight mr. Leonard Maltin
thank you please sit down it's very nice
to have such a great turnout I feel like
I'm a football field away from you wish
we could compress the distance and I
have to watch popping my piece too but
I'm very happy to be here and I'm very
happy to see such a life turn out as I
was for the screening this afternoon
where most of you they're good
I was I was pleased but not shocked at
how well the movie played today not
shocked because I have hosted and
introduced a number of other showings of
Frank Capra movies over the years and he
had such a great sense of audience he
the last he built in to those films
still resound today it's it's almost
uncanny I showed one of his films called
State of the Union a film I like very
much with Spencer Tracy and Katharine
Hepburn to a class I teach at USC in Los
Angeles and we have a big big class
three hundred and sixty students most of
them not film majors most of them are
from all disciplines around the campus
it's kind of a film appreciation course
and we showed new movies every week but
the last night of the semester I try to
show an older film if we can get a guest
from that film and I was very lucky that
night that the co-star that film Angela
Lansbury came it was a wonderful night
and I thought the film would play well
it's it's it's it's a 1948 movie that
was based on a hit Broadway show and
it's about a presidential election it's
it's still pretty contemporary and it's
ideas but there are certain things about
it they were topical that I thought I
ought to tell the class about things
they might not automatically
a lot of topical jokes about about Harry
Truman the fact that radio was the
dominant medium communication medium
then and television was just in its
infancy and and that's referred to in
the film Van Johnson plays a campaign
manager who today one would call sexist
but in the 40s they called him a wolf
and a wolf was seen that a little more
there's more tolerance I think of wolves
back then than there would be if
somebody would be accused of being
sexist today so it's context it's always
about context so I try to set that up
and the film started and I could feel
the class starting to get into the
rhythm of the movie and toward the end
of the film there's a scene where
there's a televised campaign hour and
it's coming from Spencer Tracy and
Katharine Hepburn's home and it's very
intrusive the TV crew was there and
there's a lot of hubbub going on and in
a side room
Tracy's hired an old crony of his to
tend bar and the chrony was played by a
character actor named Irving Bacon he's
the one and it happened one night who
was the filling station guy who says he
you know he doesn't want the suitcase
but he could use a hat that's Irving
Bacon he's in literally hundreds of
movies always a small role sometimes
bigger than that but he was a supporting
player but Frank Capra one of one of the
hallmarks of his career wasn't loyalty
he used he turned to the same people on
both sides of the camera over and over
again including actors like Irving Bacon
so he cast him as this bartender and he
uses him in the scene that the scene has
a lot a lot of things going on at once
and one of the things is there's a
showdown between Katharine Hepburn who
is Tracy's estranged wife and Angela
Lansbury who is his mistress
and it was kind of a power broker in
Washington and all this is happening
intention is building Capra repeatedly
cuts to Irving bacon behind the bar to
do a take or a reaction or do some bit
of business with with mixing a drink and
every it's used as punctuation a sort of
comic punctuation for the scene every
one of those moments got the laugh from
my students every one of them decades
after the movie was made nothing about
this movie resembles a current movie and
yet it was hitting the bull's eye with a
contemporary a young contemporary
audience that's Frank Capra at his best
I mean the the the topic I'm supposed to
be addressing tonight is what makes
Frank Capra a great director well that's
one of the things this kinship with his
audience he didn't do market research he
didn't do focus groups he he previewed
his movies and learned things from the
previews and there are many famous
stories some of them true some of them
legendary almost about making changes in
his films after preview so it's not that
he was infallible but he did have a very
real sense of who was sitting in that
audience and how they would respond but
he didn't do it alone a great director
surrounds himself with great people and
that's one of the other things he did he
had a great writing partner his writer
was Robert Riskin Robert risk and wrote
it happened one night and won the Oscar
for it
capper and Riskin made I think ten
movies together they made history
together they grew their careers
blossomed together and Riskin was a
great great screenwriter but oddly
Riskin was never as successful on his
own
as he was with Capra and Capra's career
had some missteps after he broke with
Riskin and there been essays written
about this and much speculation about
who's really the dominant partner who's
really responsible for those movies well
it's not an easy answer there was only
one man behind the camera when they were
being shot and supervising the editing
and that was the director
but the director couldn't have done what
he did without a great screenplay
every movie is a collaboration but but
Capra was the dominant force I was lucky
enough to get to know someone who was on
his crew he was the sound the sound
recordist
on these movies his name was Edward
Burns unusual last name BER NDS burns
IDI was a great guy who I was very lucky
to get to know and by the way I have to
work with Joe where are you sitting
right here I'm blinded by the humanity
here stand up and take about this is
Joseph McBride who's gonna be speaking
tomorrow and I'm a little intimidated
giving this speech with Joe sitting here
because Joe wrote a magnificent book
about Frank Capra and knows Frank
Capra's life and career as well as if
not better than anybody on the planet so
I'm doing the best I can Joe and I hope
I don't make any mistakes and if I do
you will correct me or you'll amend what
I said tomorrow Joe and I both got to
know this fellow Edward Burns Edie was a
sound recordist which means he's the guy
with the headset who was actually
listening to the actors on microphone as
the scenes were being shot what made him
special for people like Joe and me was
he was a great observer
he wanted to be a filmmaker himself and
eventually became one both a writer and
a director mostly he did short subjects
and a lot of B movies and never really
ascended to the top ranks of directors
but when he was recording sound he paid
attention
he kept Diaries and he's of researchers
dream come true and he worked with Capra
for at least 10 years at Columbia and
and and admired him no end and got to
see and got to hear him at work on the
set that was about as intimate
relationship as you could get and the
loyalty that Frank Capra had toward his
key people like the great
cinematographer I spoke up before Joseph
Walker was reciprocated everybody wanted
to do their best for him and that's one
of the marks of a great director I once
asked an actor who worked for John Ford
a number of times what he thought made
Ford special and he said it was like
being on a on a football team with an
inspiring coach and when you go in for
every play you want to do your best for
your coach that's how he felt about Ford
so wasn't any one thing that Ford would
say or do it was just the the vibe that
he sent out to his team and a movie crew
is a team both the actors and the people
behind the scenes Capra was a great
coach I met a number of actors who
worked for him both in leading roles and
in some of these small supporting roles
they adored Frank Capra because they
knew he cared about them he treated them
with great respect and great care not
every director did some of these some of
the support
some of the the people in the smaller
roles were just so much filling up so
much space on a set to some directors
especially some of the more routine or
b-movie directors just come and get it
done do your job go home
Capra never treated people like that
there's a there's a wonderful photograph
that I suppose you could find online I
know where you can find it physically
there's a book called the It's a
Wonderful Life book to which I was a
contributor it's edited by Jeanine
Basinger who presides over the Frank
Capra archives at Wesleyan University in
Connecticut and in the end papers of the
book see young B you remember books
right I just wanna you know they've got
a binding his pages anyway end papers
the end papers of this book are a giant
panoramic photo that was taken at a
picnic celebrating the end of shooting
of It's a Wonderful Life today they call
him a wrap party but Frank Capra wanted
to have an old-fashioned picnic he
wanted to this he just made this movie
there was a slice of Americana and he
wanted to have celebration that was in
keeping with that so they had a picnic
and they had three-legged races and the
kind of things you'd have in a
archetypal American July 4th type picnic
and they hired a cameraman who had what
they used to call a panoramic camera and
the way a panoramic camera used to used
to work with so it would take a very
wide photo of a big group of people and
it meant a long exposure and it would
start over here and it would slowly move
like this there's a still camera but
they had exposed a very large negative
and it would end over here and then
you'd have this big long print they used
to do it at summer camps used to do it
at some schools and graduations and
that's what they did here so
Frank Capra and his star Jimmy Stewart
are standing at the extreme left of the
group in the photo and as soon as that
panoramic camera started moving capper
said to Stewart come on and they ran to
the other end and so they're in the
picture twice and as I say it's in the
end papers of the It's a Wonderful Life
book and by now I'm sure somebody has
copied it online I hope you can find it
later on it tells you something it tells
you something about the personality of
the man if you look in Capra's own book
the name above the title there are a
number of cast photos that he would have
posed with all the principal actors and
they would all sign it and he kept them
as as souvenirs of the movies that he
made all these things add up to give you
an idea of the kind of person he was
kind of personality and then if you read
even the most cursory outline of his
life you begin to get an idea of what
shaped him he was born in Sicily he came
here at the age of six under the worst
possible conditions with his mother and
father his brother had already come to
America and settled in Southern
California at age six you're aware of
what's going on and he never forgot that
trip and how awful it was and when the
Capra fad and they spoke no English the
cappers when they arrived in Los Angeles
Frank very young had to work as well as
going to school he got up at the crack
of dawn and sold newspapers for two
cents on the streets he he did all
manner of odd jobs but he he turned out
to be a great student
a really great student he excelled and
he excelled in spite of all the
handicaps of having to cold down these
various jobs he attended a school that
became the California Institute of
Technology
and so he was a very very bright young
man he had ambition he he he lived the
an embodied what we used to call the
American dream he really was the the
embodiment of the American success story
an immigrant who comes here with nothing
almost literally nothing and built built
a life and a career what else did he
have he had Drive he had ambition he was
going to succeed he was determined to
succeed at whatever it was he was going
to try he was going to succeed now it
didn't happen magically and it didn't
happen overnight
either he kind of fell into the movie
business as many people did in the
silent film days remember if you were
growing up in the early part of the 20th
century it was unlikely that you had
career ambitions in the motion picture
field
what motion picture field it was also
new it was also primitive then now
around the time that that Capra became
it was turning to his adolescent years
the movie business was starting to
starting to get its act together and it
was starting to become more of a
codified business in Los Angeles but it
was still wild and wooly
and there were no rules it was an
anything-goes kind of kind of atmosphere
and they were room for it was room for
entrepreneurs there was room for
hucksters
who took advantage of people all these
things happen during the silent film era
and it was possible for almost anybody
to break in and he did and he proved
himself slowly but surely working in
comedy films working ultimately for the
great comedy producer Mack Sennett the
man who discovered Charlie Chaplin the
man who put Chaplin on film the man who
put many great comedy stars onto the
screen for the first time and his latest
discovery was a was a comedic actor from
the stage from vaudeville named Harry
Langdon Capra wound up working as a gag
writer on the Harry langdon movies and
then got a chance to direct Langdon as
well that was his first taste of real
success but there were missteps along
the way there too he and Langdon had a
falling-out Langa's Ito got out of
control and he had to start all over
again luckily he crossed the path of men
and Harry Cohn who was running with
Columbia Pictures what would become
Columbia Pictures I think it already had
become Columbia by then it was
originally called CBC Harry and his
brother Jack started this company as I
mentioned before it happened one night
Columbia was kind of one of the
scrappier
Studios not a big entrenched corporation
a ramshackle outfit in fact that was and
a lot is still there in Hollywood itself
not in the San Fernando Valley not on
the west side of town like the others
right smack in the heart of Hollywood
and Capra and Harry Cohn blossomed
together because Harry Cohn had
everything to gain and nothing to lose
but by giving this young ambitious guy a
chance to do the kind of films he wanted
to do and with each success on the rung
of the ladder Capra wanted to try
something new something different
something more inventive something he
hadn't done before
and then he was lucky enough to hook up
with Robert risking the writer and Joe
Walker the cameraman and a young actress
just out from New York named Barbara
Stanwyck and they two blossomed together
he had what was called the common touch
now it's been read into and interpreted
by in many many ways
he and his in his autobiography refer to
what he did as Capricorn he coined that
term I don't know if it did he coin it
or to the journalist coin and I don't
remember but he became the populist hero
of the Depression years because he made
films that lifted your spirits literally
lifted your spirits you felt better
walking out of the theater having seen
it happened one night or lady for a day
or mr. deeds goes to town or mr. Smith
goes to Washington or any number of
other films
that's what endeared him to the great
American public and to great many
critics and members of the press as well
he seemed to have just a credible feel
for making films that touched at the
heart of humanity the part that gets
complicated I know Joe will talk about
this in greater detail is that in order
to show in order to earn a happy ending
in order to show people at their best
people who were worth admiring people
who were worth emulating he also showed
humanity at its worst it can't be light
without dark and you have to sometimes
go through a trial to come to a
resolution and he understood that and so
did Robert Riskin so
some people have complained almost
because they feel people have been
blinded to the fact that Capra didn't
just paint a rosy picture of life that
wasn't what made people happy what made
people happy was that he took them
through a process that led them to that
happy ending I mean here's the ultimate
example It's a Wonderful Life It's a
Wonderful Life is sort of the ultimate
example of this what is it about it's
about a man who finds like the Bluebird
of happiness in his own backyard that
life can be wonderful if you appreciate
what's right in front of you that maybe
your far-flung dreams and ambitions are
misplaced and that you can you can
really realize your dreams and your
potential right at home but how does he
show us that by having a man sink so low
that he wants to and does commit suicide
what could be darker than suicide it's a
very dark film the scene where Jimmy
Stewart breaks down at the bar famously
Stewart had such a tough time doing this
scene and did it so beautifully the
Capra was reluctant to ask him for a
second take didn't know if he had it in
him and didn't want to put him through
that so so it's the camera moves in on
him to an optical effect that they did
in the lab they sort of enlarged the
photos zoomed in artificially it had
been shot with this stationary camera
this a man destroyed his spirit is is
destroyed but he gets it back so that
when you get to that ending when you get
to that finale you've earned the right
to cheer for Jimmy Stewart and the
people of the town
who even if they were fickle even if
they were unbelieving even if they were
harsh or cruel ultimately come around
and ultimately do the right thing and
say the right thing and restore Jimmy
Stewart's faith in himself as well as
his his town his family his extended
family in Bedford Falls that's what
Frank Capra was capable of doing but not
infallible one of the great fascinations
of his career is how and why he seemed
to lose that magic touch at a certain
time how could a man so gifted how could
a man who had so much at his command
stumble as he did well some of the
reasons are pragmatic and kind of
mundane he and a couple of other top
drawer filmmakers wanted after World War
two wanted to control their own destiny
and started their own company Liberty
films if you see It's a Wonderful Life
there's the logo of the Liberty Bell at
the beginning but they were artists they
were not businessmen and it didn't work
out
and he and George Stevens and William
Wyler wasn't the three of them nobody
none of them work fast in order to keep
a company going you have to have
constant product and that that's what
the studio's could do that's how the
studio's functioned the studio's
function by putting out 50 films a year
in those days and some of them were junk
but it kept the wheels turning they
could subsidize failure Capra and his
partners couldn't so then he became a
director for hire and he made a couple
of pleasant movies with Bing Crosby who
was a top box-office star to Paramount
he remade one of his own
in fact Broadway bill he remade with
Bing Crosby is riding high it's a pretty
exact remake they even used stock
footage from the original film there's
nothing wrong with the movie as I say
it's a pleasant movie to watch so is the
next one he made with Bing Crosby called
here comes the groom they're both
likable movies but in a sense if almost
anybody with a certain modicum of talent
could have made those movies they
weren't stamped Frank Capra movies as
indelibly as the earlier ones had been
and if you believe his autobiography he
knew it he spent a lot of time in that
book talking about his meditations his
anxieties his self down and what Joe
McBride does in his book is he examines
and dissects cappers autobiography
because there's a lot of embellishment
in Frank's storytelling and he gets to
the truth behind some of the self
mythology that Capra perpetuated but the
part that's true is that he did have
self-doubt and he did know at those
moments that things were not as they
should have been this was the man who
was the king of the movie business with
box office success and Academy Awards to
prove it
and the envy and the respect and
adoration of the audience so listen
maybe maybe not every artist maybe not
every career is meant to last forever
and maybe you know with the benefit of
hindsight we look back at some people's
output and we say well that was their
peak period and though they kept working
you know maybe that was not their best
work but they kept trying but you can
identify this is when they really hit
the bull's eye and should we be critical
of that should we be harsh in our
judgement of somebody for that
I don't think so it's it's kind of an
ingrate attitude isn't it what have you
done for me lately and that's that's
what some people say Hollywood is like
all the time what have you done for me
lately I'm sure you've made a great
movie ten years ago what about those
last two turkeys that does happen now
I'm as guilty of it as anybody sometimes
they'll say well this was fun wasn't
this doesn't measure up you're looking
at a new movie well maybe it doesn't
measure up but does that mean you've
lost your talent does that mean you're
to be dismissed I hope not
I hope they get another shot Capra found
other outlets he did this wonderful bell
science series in the 50s for television
that several generations of school kids
came to watch and to know and and to and
to enjoy and then when he realized that
with this last couple of films that the
business had changed he was no longer
given the freedom that he had that he
enjoyed with Harry Cohn at Columbia even
though we fought for those things maybe
it was worth considering retiring and
not to use this phrase judgmentally to
rest on his laurels this is the man who
made mr. Smith goes to Washington
it happened one night mr. deeds goes to
town it's a wonderful life you know
that's enough of the headstone isn't it
that's that's a that's an awful lot
that's an awful lot to admire and that's
why I think Frank Capra will always be
celebrated as a great director always
doesn't mean everything he touched was
pure gold doesn't mean everything he did
was great but he he made so many great
movies and so many good movie
that they tower so high that no amount
of failure if you want to even use that
word but no amount of failure on either
side of that mountain and take away from
that achievement I feel very blessed
that I got to meet him just once and
chat with him for a few minutes it was
when his book had just come out and he
came to New York it was such a thrill
just to get to talk to him for a couple
of minutes and asked him to sign his
book so I feel ok I was in the presence
of greatness and I don't think anybody
would ever dispute or deny Frank Capra
was a great director that's my spiel I
want to open this up to questions so we
can talk about what you're interested in
and so thank you very much
nope not long yet this usually happens
when I try to operate a microphone check
oh okay
now we're all the way it works thank you
very much mr. Moulton we have some time
for questions please raise your hand and
the microphone will be brought to you
student questions are encouraged and
please also stand up when the microphone
is brought to you thank you very very
much for sharing your warm feelings
about mr. Capra and the reasons for them
with your expertise and your passion for
film would you could you if someone came
to you and said here I will finance this
would you direct and if so what would
you direct if somebody handed me on a
platter the opportunity to make a movie
well even a small platter
even a small platter yes Oh in a shot
and you know in a moment without
hesitation I made some amateur movies
with my friends when I was in junior
high school but I could never scale my
thinking down to our modest capabilities
back then eight millimeter silent movie
camera you can make great films an eight
millimeter silent will be camera you
just have to conceive of them is eight
millimeter silent films you can't have a
Hollywood movie in your head and expect
to reproduce that and that's that's so I
could never achieve that and then many
years later a friend of mine who is
really brilliant about screenwriting and
story structure said why don't we try
writing something together and we did we
wrote a couple of treatments and we're
able to get some meetings in Hollywood
with some very highly placed development
people networks and studios and they
were all very bright and they were it's
not like those satires you see about you
know of Hollywood these were these were
smart
people they'd read our stuff then you
are stuff they engaged us in interesting
conversations about what if we did this
and what have you changed that and then
at the end of these meetings there was
no conclusion I thought well maybe if we
did the things they asked us to do
they'd want to buy the but buy the story
or buy the script no they were just
taking up time at a meeting
that's a their job is to have meetings
I'm not exaggerating that's their job to
have meetings and I said to my friend I
can't do this I come out of freelance
writing where if you're trying to sell
an article to an editor either says nah
not interested or ya give me a thousand
words a week from Thursday we'll pay you
500 bucks that's a conclusion to a
conversation or a meeting if you're
trying to sell a book and you have some
track record you talk to an editor at a
publishing company chances are they'll
say well we're having an editorial board
meeting next week we'll consider it
we'll let you know and then they let you
know no we're not interested yes we're
interested that's a conclusion and
Hollywood they just have meetings but it
wasn't a waste of so I I bowed out the
writing part was so wonderful and
creative and stimulating but the rest of
it wasn't
I found it draining so the the payoff
though was that it gave me great and
renewed and deepened admiration for
people who can put up with all of that
to get a movie made it means that like
the this young fellow Damien Chazelle
just made whiplash god bless him not
only did he made a really good movie but
that he went through whatever he had to
go through to get that movie made i
admired all the more but no one has come
to me with that offer on a platter so
well thank you so much first of all for
coming out you touched on briefly that
Capra has been perceived by some to have
lost his touch at a certain point and I
think when you look at his career you
see this dividing line of the propaganda
films why we fight those other films in
the world war ii period do you think
that had a discernible effect on his
directing style can that be traced
I mean his post-war work
how do you think that affected him well
the war obviously had a profound effect
on everybody
and if you haven't read mark Harris's
great book 5 came back which was
published last year I urge you to do it
he he profiles the five most important
Hollywood directors who became involved
in filmmaking during the war and he
reveals new information that was not
commonly known if known at all
and really gives you an understanding of
how just how much the wartime
experiences affected these men these
five great great directors so there's no
question that it you know it you know it
went deep deep inside and of course it
was right after the war that he made
it's a wonderful life his darkest film
so that's not a coincidence maybe it
made it tough for him to do the kind of
lighter hearted films that that he was
trying to make I don't know and maybe
maybe it just robbed him of a little bit
of ambition because he wasn't sure where
to channel his energies and how best to
harness his his ambition and energy to
make the kind of films he had made
before hello my questions just
pertaining to like how we looked at
great directors of the past it seems
like we often like look at them in terms
of how progressive they were both for
society and for the film industry as a
whole like Kubrick and Spielberg what
would you say Capra's like what was the
primary mark that he left on American
society and the film industry as a whole
well there's a two part answer to that
I'm sorry to keep doing that to the my
first off he had a great influence
within the the film industry he was the
president of the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences at a very
turbulent time for that institution it
had started as a kind of company Union
sponsored by the major studios and that
got the Academy embroiled in labor
strife during the 1930s and a lot of
people boycotted the Oscars in the mid
to late 30s when Capra was president
because they didn't think the Academy
should be involved in those matters he
rode through that storm and helped set
the Academy on the on the right path he
was also president the directors guild
he said he did a lot of interesting and
significant things for the motion
picture industry so that's on that's one
facet of what he did I think for film in
general I think he I think he emphasized
the human qualities that every great
director aspires to capture on screen in
his best films he really touches he
touches a nerve he touches our heart as
well as our mind and that may sound a
little too vague but if you look at the
dozens of other films that came out
surrounding his films that couldn't come
close to achieving what he did you see
how tough it was to do what he did
other people aspired to it he did it I
think he still set a kind of a
high-water mark that that that
filmmakers can still learn from and and
benefit from as I say there were there
there were so many imitators of it
happen one lot one night carbon copies
attempts to to recapture the exact same
kind of story the same ingredients the
same elements and almost none of them
could come close why not they had the
they had the blueprint but they didn't
have his touch and I think even a
director today given given all the
particulars of making a movie today any
movie maker would still benefit from
watching his films and seeing what he
was able to do and trying to emulate
that listen the best comic book
superhero movies are ones that make us
care about the characters it's not the
visual effects visual effects are
important it's not the you know the the
bells and whistles they're significant
too but it's it's it's the character of
the characters great writing great
directing so I think I think he is still
an exemplar I think even in the 21st
century thank you again for joining us
in this brisk Michigan climate I wanted
to ask you a question about his
experience as an immigrant coming to
this country because you spoke a bit
about how this impacted his life and
they said there's obviously
psychological impact what did this have
to do with his did this have any impact
on his films and any film in particular
being an immigrant from Sicily it's a
perfectly good question it's a very good
question and and it's a tough one for me
to answer with specifics he didn't deal
very much with with immigrants
as set as protagonists or central
characters in his films but I can't help
but think that everything he did wasn't
informed by who he was and what he
experienced you know what makes one film
or one piece of art of any kind of
painting a novel a short story a musical
composition what makes one different
from another it's the person who created
it who is that person that person's the
sum of many parts so I can't give you a
specific that you know this young
ambitious kid from Sicily brought that
specific point to that specific movie
but he was who he was because of all
those things he experienced I'm sorry
that's not that's a general answer to a
specific question but I don't think I
could make it more specific than that
you know it's been said justjust sorry
there's an old axiom about the fact that
that generation of filmmakers that he
was part of came up in the silent movie
era they lived lives they were Cowboys
in some cases they were they worked on
[ __ ] steamers they they herded cattle
some of them were in barnstorming
theater troops traveling around the
country they had an incredibly varied
set of backgrounds they lived life they
didn't go to film school because there
was no such thing as film school so what
they brought there what what they
brought to their ultimate career was
life experience and there are people who
say in a very generalized way that
that's what's wrong with a lot of recent
and current movies that the people
making them have learned about life from
watching other movies
instead of doing interesting things and
being out in the world Capra had a world
of experience almost literally like all
of his contemporaries and he brought
that to every everything that he did as
a filmmaker sorry to keep you yeah you
spoke of loyalty early on in your speech
I was thinking about how there are
several different actors who reoccur in
Frank Capra's films Jimmy Stewart the
actor who portrays uncle Billy and is a
wonderful life do you think they were
drawn to those films because of Capra or
were they did they have contracts with
Colombia or was it both what do you
think no it was him requesting those
actors in some cases there were actors
under contract I think Walter Connelly
who plays Claudette Colbert father was
under contract to Columbia Pictures at
this time in the 30s and Roscoe Karns
who plays mr. shapely I think may have
also been under contract they are both
in Howard Hawks 20th century the same
year made at Columbia and they're both
wonderful in that movie but mostly when
Capra had the clout that he ultimately
had he could request actors Oh Jean
Arthur his great leading lady first
Barbara Stanwyck was under contract to
Columbia in the early 30s then Jean
Arthur was under contract in the mid 30s
through the early 40s so he had access
to these two wonderful actresses and
that was a happy circumstance for him
and he may have even encouraged for all
I know Harry Cohn to sign them or
re-sign them because they worked so well
together but in those supporting players
he would often a lot of them were
freelance actors guy plays uncle Billy
Thomas Mitchell was a freelance actor
that he would have requested
specifically and Lionel Barrymore who
played mr. Potter was under contract to
MGM a long-term contract to MGM and
Capra had to borrow him from MGM for him
to appear in it's a wonderful
so he sought those people out he made a
point of hiring them it wasn't just a
matter of you know their availability or
the convenience of than being at the
studio
the mood come this is a frivolous
question I counted about four or five
nights in the movie but first of all
night picky picky picky I have no other
response but you're dead right I never
thought about it before
should we call that happen one week
there's some folks in the back hang on
they want they want to bring a mic to
you so hang on just a second sorry um hi
I noticed in a lot of the movies there's
a reoccurring theme of suicide whether
it's a mr. Smith goes to Washington not
to give a spoiler but at the attempt of
suicide by the senior senator and then
of course we all know it's a wonderful
life and then even the movie tonight it
was referenced during the the
threatening scene is there a reasoning
behind that or am I reading too much
into it well as I say I think the
reasoning is that the Capra went to dark
places and was willing to go to dark
places in his storytelling meet John Doe
has some very dark things to meet John
Doe is not a completely successful movie
but a fascinating movie and with Gary
Cooper and Barbara Stanwyck and and
suicide plays a part there too and
that's not a spoiler but it's I think
that's the only answer I can give it's
it's a short answer but I think it's
it's it's it's it's the right one when
you want to show despair you have to
show despair in order to earn the
happiness that follows I think that was
his MO
like everyone else thank you very much
for being here
who are the modern-day Frank Capra's or
are there any modern-day Frank Capra's
well I don't know and it's an unfair
thing to try to compare I think you know
Capra had the benefit during his golden
years he had the benefit of this
long-term relationship with a studio
which was a stable operation where as I
say it was cut Studios in those days in
the 30s and 40s were really movie
factories where things hummed along on
an assembly line and the people with
talent the people with ambition and the
people who earned either the respect or
earned the clout that brought them
respect from the studio Chiefs got to
work in a somewhat somewhat worryfree
atmosphere compared to today every film
today is its own project has to be
financed most important they've got to
raise the money to make the movie club
the Sony or paramount or Fox or any of
these studios today they don't have an
unlimited line of credit at a bank that
they can just parcel out every movie has
to be you know has to be financed in
some manner and that means every movie
starts from scratch from scratch at
Columbia in the 30s the only question
was what do you want to do next Frank
they were ready when he was and so given
that enormous sea change in the way
movies are made in Hollywood
I know that's kind of a business answer
rather than an artistic or a creative
answer but I think it it has a big
effect on the the personality of a
filmmaker and the ability of the
filmmaker to follow his vision or her
vision it's not easy to do
some people manage some people you know
try and succeed but it's it's very hard
I think in his early years Steven
Spielberg carried some some of Capra's
magic on his shoulders because he too
seemed to have that I don't it's quite
the right word but the common touch the
the means to to speak to a vast audience
not one demographic but a vast
movie-going audience and he did and he
still does you know but you know not
every film hits the bull's eye but he's
still a great great talent it's the only
one that comes comes right to mind
they're they're independent filmmakers
like Tom McCarthy who made the station
agent and a lot of other really good
films
who who I think doesn't have very much
superficially in common with Capra but
he's a guy who's a writer and director
who has a passion to tell very personal
stories very human stories and I think
he he has some of those qualities this
will be our final question I'm just
curious to know I know that Frank
Capra's education at Cal Tech played
some role in his making of submarine but
how definitive or how impactful of most
of his works was that time at Cal Tech I
don't have a I don't have a good answer
I'm sorry it's the last questions I have
a good answer for it you know I would
again I think everything-everything you
experience especially as a young person
that helps form and shape you pays off
and what you do later on so you know
whether or not it was
refusal to participate in bogus science
or to you know give proper respect to to
higher education you know there any
number of ways you can you can examine
you know what that college experience
may have meant to him he did return to
science ultimately for those bill system
documentaries he did in the 50s which
were enormous ly popular and which
allowed him and enabled him to make
science entertaining that was the the
great gift he gave my generation of
school kids who saw those films he found
ways to turn what could have been a dull
classroom lesson into a piece of of
stimulating entertainment that gave us
food for thought and explained science
and in ways that we could all understand
that may have been the ultimate payoff
from his Caltech experience and I think
it must have given him enormous
satisfaction to do so
I'm very I'm very grateful for your
attention and for your for your interest
and I want to congratulate the school
for celebrating Frank Capra you know
there's a there are a lot of people who
to whom an old movie is the Empire
Strikes Back I'm not kidding you say
well you ever watch old movies yeah sure
I watch the Star Wars trilogy no it's
not what I mean
felt you know only movies I think it
labeled as old nobody talks about going
to see a performance of that old
Beethoven symphony or that old
Shakespeare play or that old Mark Twain
novel or that old Rembrandt painting but
movies I think because they're a popular
art form and a lot of people don't even
think of them as an art at all but
simply is a piece of entertainment they
get labeled old and the other misused
word that bugs me is nostalgia well I
wasn't born when Frank Capra made these
movies so I can't if you look up the
dictionary definition I can't be
nostalgic about them I didn't experience
them the first time around it means that
something in them still speaks to me
today something in them still speaks to
you today that means they're in a way
they're there they're timeless even
though they're specific to their time
period but something about them still
keeps them alive and even the ones that
aren't great are alive because they're
interesting
they reflect something of the time
period they reflect something of the
Society at the time they were made
social issues that were going on the the
manners and mores of the time the
fashions of the time all of those things
so I never think of these as old movies
I just think of them as will be still
worth watching and thank you for doing
just that
very much